شيئاني لا يمكن استرجاعهما الوقت
والانطباع الاول الوقت لم يكن ليصبح اكثر
مثاليه فاليوم هو يوم تتويج الملك وقرينته
الف عام من تاريخ النظام الملكي اما
الانطباع فيتم تجهيز له بعنايه فائقه لرسم
الصوره الملكيه بتفاصيلها العائله الازياء
والمجوهرات وبالطبع الارث
وهنا سنتحدث عن الاطباع الذي تركه افراد
العائله الملكيه في اذهان الشعب البريطاني
من خلال تعابير ورسائل الاطلاله التي
يتقنها ويتفنن بتفكيك شفراتها مواطنوا
المملكه المتحده
ولعل اكثر ما لفت ولمس قلوب البريطانيين
هو رؤيه اميرتهم المفضله ديانا يتم
تكريمها من قبل كيت زوجتي ويليام ولي
العهد كيت اميره ويلز احتفت بحماتها
باكمال مجموعتها الفاخره باقراط مرصعه
بالماس ولؤلؤ البحر الجنوبي تطابق تلك
التي ارتدتها ديانا طوال التسعينات التاج
لكن ليس تاج الملكه بلكيت ايضا كندا مغزى
ودلالات مهمه فبينما وقفت ميدلتون بجانب
زوجها واطفالها الثلاثه كانت لها لحظه
مطابقه مع ابنتها حيث نسقت للاميره
تشارلوت مع والدتها في عرض وحده الاسره
رباط شعر نباتي متلالئ مماثل وفستان من
تصميم اليكساندر ماكوين في ثوب المحكمه
الابيض
اما صوره النموذجيه كانت من نصيب الملك
تشارلز الذي توج بتاج القديس ادوارد من
عام
1661 الى جانبه الملكه كمال التي توجت
بتاج الملكه ميري واحتفالا بشغف الزوجين
بالطبيعه في هذا اليوم التاريخي كانت
تطريز الزهور البريه البريطانيه ظاهره على
فستان قرينه الملك وهي تتشابك مع الرايات
الرسميه بصوره مبهجه وواعده كرم حناوي
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات